this is a production of cornell
university
all right thanks very much bill and and
if we were in texas here would be my
official greeting howdy
there you go at texas a m if we do
anything twice it's a new tradition
right so it's it's just the way we do
things
and if it works to beat alabama and
football we'll do it right whatever it
takes i do appreciate the uh the
invitation to come back to ithaca it has
been almost a decade since i was last
here there's a lot of new things that
i've seen on campus to do bioswell along
the road here is is new
and uh there's a few trees i didn't
remember being quite that big so it was
uh interesting to see the changing flora
when coming back to ithaca
this is a unique place uh just like
texas a m is unique in its own right
this is a unique uh within academia this
is a unique institution from its
diversity of flora and fauna and from
the diversity inclusion which you guys
have been embracing for decades long
before the nation found it cool to talk
about diversity and inclusion so i
appreciate the opportunity to come and
speak and let's get started
the title for this presentation actually
came to me
in the shower as most of my good ideas
come and i was in the shower and said
wow that would be a great title i got to
remember the right opportunity to use
that so searching for the end of
uncertainty now right away i'm going to
steal my own thunder and say that this
holy grail of uncertainty is something
that we shouldn't even pursue
because it's it's not necessarily even
possible to get into a situation with
full degree of certainty
so
the search for the end of uncertainty is
not really the question what is the
question is
how soon will we get back to some degree
of normalcy
well the short answer is
forget that so it ain't happening we're
not going to go back to the way in which
we
engaged before now
some might lament the fact that this is
happening however from an economic point
of view there are actually some
opportunities that are going to arise
out of the pandemic that we would not
have had otherwise and indeed we saw
many different changes
during the pandemic the e-commerce
sector for example
grew in one year
the equivalent to five to seven years of
growth in one year because of the
pandemic the way in which we learn
has changed and we simply won't go back
to 100 percent in person even at
conferences in the nursery and floral
industry we're going to see a hybrid of
educational opportunities for members to
engage in so it just makes sense that we
use the technologies and the skill sets
that we have developed during the
pandemic
for other educational and industry
applications
all right so
let me talk about what was happening in
in the green industry i'm going to focus
my comments on the green industry but
certainly whether it be
the viticulture industry whether it be
the vegetable industry there are other
applications there are certainly
applications what i'm talking about to
those industries as well then i'll talk
about how covet affected the industry in
20 and 21 and then what does a
post-covered green industry look like
which is again applicable to non-green
industry industries
so before covid you know we were 128
months into uh the longest
expansionary time period that our
country has ever seen
all through the obama years and the
trump years our economy grew at an
average between two and two and a
quarter percent
right and you and and the rhetoric
politically is always
elect me so we can gain three or four
percent on our economy
um and that's simply not going to happen
we have 22 trillion dollar economy
and it takes a lot of of economic growth
to grow at three four five percent now
we're going to be more than that this
year
however it took a pandemic
a collapse for us to grow with that rate
in the aftermath
holding all of the things constant we've
been growing at two percent we were 128
months
extending new record
up until the pandemic housing was
peaking or so we thought
is it still in the midst of peaking we
couldn't even spell the word inflation
we didn't know what inflation was there
are students that have have grown up in
this time period for the last decade who
didn't know
what inflationary pressures were
right so that's certainly changed
consumption was steady but consumption
is always steady we as a consumer we
spend uh represent our spending
represents about 70 percent of gdp
so we do our job as consumers we're
going to spend our dollars right
particularly the baby boomers all the
baby boomers in the house and let's move
it up right because
we can't even spell the word inheritance
right we're going to spend all of our
kids in heritage
so all you all you kids are boomers
you're out of luck we're spending your
inheritance
consumption steady job growth with
slowing
but it was still growing and of course
the stock market was fairly steady again
a fairly even increase in the stock
market all through the obama years and
the trump years and so there's not
really a trump bump as you'll hear
in many instances it's really constant
so
i as an economist i'm i'm quite frankly
i don't
i worry less about who's in the white
house
i worry more about who's the chair of
the federal reserve than i do who's in
the white house
all right so you see this particular uh
supply chain diagram every i thought i
would uh jokingly i thought i would i
would just come in with this one slide
and then just speak from that one slide
which i have done in class before right
but but i want to mix it up a little bit
so it's the three numbers i want to call
out to you right you got the the allied
trade sector manufacturers down there at
the bottom you got the growers in the
circle there and i see some folks taking
pictures
by all means go ahead
but you're an email away from getting
this powerpoint
right if you want this powerpoint i'll
send you the powerpoint i won't send you
a pdf
you can use the powerpoint right i'll
send it to you it'll be yours for free
it's out of date tomorrow anyway
because economic times change rapidly
right that's what key that's why i have
job security
so growers are in the middle on the
right hand side you've got the landscape
service sector on the left hand side
you've got the retail sector and then
the almighty consumer at the top so
that's the green industry supply chain
that negative 16
means that there's 16 percent fewer
growers
in the green industry today
than there were prior to the great
recession back in 2007
so we've lost
16 of our growers
not all of that productive capacity left
the industry
some of it's under a different name
right like color spot was bought out by
altman plants for example
so
on the retail side we're down five
percent there was some consolidation but
there were some retailers that just went
out particularly independent lawn and
garden retailers garden centers
but you got on the landscape side
plus 17
are you freaking kidding me
17
unbelievable growth right it's tied to
housing as i said housing has been
peaking
every new house is built you got to have
flower shrubs and trees around it so we
see that increase in landscaping
services plus
landscaping is an easy entry easy exit
type of sector
have truck shovel wheelbarrow will
landscape
right so it's
less capital investment less labor
investment to get into the landscape
business so you would anticipate that
landscape services would would increase
pre-code i'm still talking pre-code so
this is consumption
of flowers seeds and potted plants
up until 2020 right so 2019
is the end year there and if you follow
the the trend line if you look at the
cursor in the trend line here that's a
fairly consistent growth but you saw the
decrease in the res in the great
recession and then it took us to about
2016
to get back to where we were prior to
the great recession and then we've grown
from there
now that's everything up pre-coveted
enter coronavirus or co
cova 19. right
supply chain
breaks
i thought this was a rather innovative
graphic i borrowed this from somebody
online i have no idea who it was because
it wasn't an attribution i generally try
to provide an attribution but that's a
neat graphic it's a supply chain
represented by that chain and you see
the coronavirus molecule
imprinted on the world
and indeed
in agriculture
horticulture specifically
we had spent four decades perfecting
a globalized supply chain
with just-in-time aspects all up and
down the supply chain
four decades we've been perfecting this
we've had various free trade agreements
that
lent to that particular development of a
globalized economy
and
because of this when you throw in a
global pandemic
and then the the rate of vaccinations
you know across the united states has
been mixed but you then you exacerbate
that by looking at the entire world and
indeed there's some countries where the
average vaccination rate right now is
still
in single digits
so it's it's a dire situation still in
some countries
so this is this is you know part of the
dilemma
is
we haven't been able to get the inputs
we have
my neighbors renovating his house
it's still shingles it looks hideous
there's no shingles but he can't get the
shingles
he can't get the windows so builders are
are hurting for supplies
green industry firms vegetable
viticulture
you name it any any sector within
agriculture and horticulture is finding
difficulty in getting inputs and they're
more costly now right here i've got a
supply chain diagram
a pressure gauge if you will
you don't have to look at the numbers
economists are going to have numbers all
over the place but don't pay attention
to the numbers
look at the colors
starting on the left hand side
you've got five different attributes of
the supply chain all these are economic
variables
what first is related to time
how quickly are products moving through
the supply chain and you can see that in
the early stages of the pandemic we're
on red alert we can't even buy toilet
paper
cleaning supplies right so we're on red
alert immediate disruption in supply
chain and then you can see that other
dimensions like volume that's similarly
impacted as red the price impacts were
not very
huge at first you still see a lot of
green
the inventories the next set of
variables
we still had fair amount of inventory
except for some of those
essentials
which is a word even today still makes
me mad
because
if anything was essential it was flower
shrubs and trees during this time period
to enhance the health and well-being of
people that are going through a health
crisis
that are under considerable pressures at
home and otherwise and managing juggling
all the plates and so forth a lot of
mental stress and so forth
we were part of the answer and yet there
were governors across this country that
said nobody's essential including you
all
so a lot of misperception a lot of
misunderstanding and a lot of lack of
knowledge a lot of ignorance about the
value of flower shrubs trees and
people's lives and the enhanced
landscapes
that that we provide
that are so so beneficial but that's a
different talk i got a whole lecture on
that as well but that's that's a
different talk
the the labor aspect is the bottom set
of attributes
and of course manufacturers and
distributors in the supply chain have
had the same
uh uh
conundrum in terms of finding labor as
we have within the green industry there
were certain sectors like trucking it
was very difficult to find truck drivers
where 80 000 drivers short projected to
be a hundred thousand drivers short by
2023
during the pandemic truck driving
schools closed
many of the car much of the cargo in our
industry has to be delivered in pairs or
teams it's harder to pair teams in the
trucking industry when you got folks
that are vaccinated some that aren't so
forth
and so we've seen higher freight rates
as a result of the higher pay for
drivers the higher prices of diesel the
higher prices of just carrying cargo we
can't find containers can't find
trailers and the containers that we do
have
uh went from like 600.
no no 6000 was the world container index
40-foot box containers that on shipping
container went from six thousand dollars
pre-pandemic
to
thirty thousand dollars today
right so that's it's
there's a lot of expenses
you see the now hiring sign
on the side of that truck back of the
truck there
almost every business in our industry
this is the have a now hiring sign
this is the the great resignation or the
great reevaluation
been called this in the media
where a number of people
10 million exact ex to be exact 10 and a
half million just three months ago
elected not to go back to work
during the midst of this covet crisis
which is still is not at
its end
that's down to about seven million
workers that have elected still not to
go back to work now why is that
well the right hand bar here
the the red portion of the bar on the
right hand side
so that's about 31
of those surveyed said they're not going
back to work at the same pay in the same
hours as what they did before
when you asked them why it was either
too long a commute they didn't like the
job that they were doing and
particularly in the service sector those
that have to interact with these
less than mature
non-intellectual
folks who were unvaccinated did i say
that
having to deal with folks in the general
public in a service setting
they said no thank you i don't want to
do that i want
i've been wanting to start my own
company for a while so i'm going to
start my own company we've seen a record
amount of entrepreneurialism
in the in the midst of the pandemic so
it's kind of offsetting the number of
business that have left we see a record
number of businesses that are
established inflation
now we can spell inflation we've we
we're even talking about terms like
stagflation which we're not heading into
yet by the way
there's two different
indicators the cpi which you normally
hear within the the media they talked
about the consumer price index and i
prefer looking at the personal
consumption expenditures index because
this is the one that the federal reserve
uses to decide on whether it's going to
raise interest rates
and that green line that two percent
target
has traditionally been
the line at which if if inflation
crosses that the federal reserve starts
raising interest rates to curb inflation
put a damper on the economy but you can
see it's almost twice the target now the
federal reserve has has
maintained that they're not going to
raise interest rates until at least this
time next year and three times the 23
2023 but i'll get to that here in a
second now they have a range in which
they're going to be patient
and they're not going to increase
interest rates uh past that range they
haven't told us what that is yet but
there's there's more patience being
exercised
this is a different dashboard this is a
consumer dashboard much like the other
one on the supply chain
except you have consumer metrics
and look you can see the red
when the pandemic started and we we
finally realized you know january and
february we weren't thinking much about
it because we weren't told much about it
and that that we were told our
leadership was was
poo-pooing so
we weren't told that much but by the
time march and april got here
and things got really busy
then you can see the consumers and all
those metrics on the red on the left
and we got to march this year and you
can see things were getting better
but what happened in march
delta all right so you had the delta
variant and and i've always said that
the
the
slope or the shape of the economic
recovery
is inversely correlated with the shape
of the covet curve
and you can see that it'll match when we
have these waves we see the decrease in
economic performance
now
how did it affect the green industry
specifically
well let's add the other bar here on the
right let's add 2020 right 2020
you can see actually increased
well that's pretty good
well okay it is
but in every economic downturn except
for the great recession that one is the
exception to the rule but in every
previous economic downturn
during that economic downturn
we would have the staycation effect
people staying at home and gardening
more landscaping more so we'd see more
lawn and garden products being sold
right
every recession and then when people
started making the switch to buying more
durable goods
more cars refrigerators furniture
windows and whatever
that's when our industry took it on the
chin and so you could look for example
back in 2002 and 2003 right here you see
we see the slight increase and then when
the recovery started for the rest of the
country that's when the sales went down
and that that first part of the year and
then it climbs after
all right so we always have that effect
this time however
i put it on the monthly basis
and there's no correla there's no the
colors don't mean anything i'm just
separating years from 16 you can see the
17
see the growth in 18 19 and 20. and hit
but here's the new trend line the dotted
line
and here's the the first six months of
june of
2021 up through june
because that's where all the data has
been corrected and everything these are
the finalized data
and you can see that every month in 2021
was higher
than 2020.
so we're above trends so
when folks were asking me last year
charlie how much do you anticipate
lawn and garden activity
increasing in 2021
should we see another 20 25 increase
like we saw in 2020 over 2019
i said i would be cautious in assuming
that i would be doing you a disservice
as an economist so take the last three
years and average it and then base five
or ten percent over that that would be a
conservative approach to estimating the
market for 2021. but bill it turned out
it was actually a pretty good year all
right now
i'm getting the same question now for
2022
to which my answer would be the same i'd
take the last three years i'd average it
if you feel aggressive go find another
five ten percent
on the growers side
covet impacted our labor availability
you can see the bullets there i'm not
going to read the bullets that would be
death by powerpoint
instead
it affected our ability to find labor
just like every other sector in america
it affected our inputs the cost of our
inputs went up um it affected the number
of plants that were sold online
we've seen some
rather aggressive growth in the online
provision of plants
since the the pandemic right and
obviously freight to everything else is
much more expensive because i calculate
an index of prices paid by growers again
a lot of numbers don't pay attention to
that look at the red box and
specifically down here i have all the
inputs
that are used by growers containers
fertilizer
um
media
the plant the the propagation materials
right the
labor
fuel energy trucking and i have them
weighted
by their relative importance in the cost
of goods sold
well how do i know that that comes back
from the benchmarking effort that you're
referring to bill that's where i collect
that data
so i have these weighted by their
importance
so even though
containers have gone up 28
just by themselves
they only represent 10.24 of cost of
goods so it doesn't have that much it
has an influence but not much of an
influence in terms of cost
our ability to grow inventory however it
has a major influence so relative to
2007 which is my base year right before
the great recession
all of these inputs are
41.5 percent more expensive today
than they were prior to the great
recession
labor itself look at this number 150.8
that means that labor is 51 more
expensive today than it was prior to the
great recession
but there's two sides of that labor
picture
there's the the business side of having
to pay those labor costs
there's the laborer side of trying to
make a livable wage
and quite frankly agriculture's been
behind in terms of creating that livable
wage
right so there's an element here that's
going to be both beneficial to
businesses
and laborers and we're seeing some of
the power base shift there more on the
labor side but in terms of
year-over-year increases look at this
neil almost eight percent
was what i was forecasting for 2021
that these this weighted averages all
these inputs are going to be eight
percent more expensive in 2021 than they
were in 2020.
for my forecast in in 2022
this was my latest revision back at
cultivate i delivered this monday
morning at the state of the industry at
cultivate
since then i just did it before i came
up here
it's five and a half percent
so you got eight percent increase plus
five and a half that's my math that's
about 18 13 and a half percent
so it's between 13 14 that tells me that
growers should be raising prices by 13
to 14
simply because the cost of inputs is
increasing
if they don't
what happens
their margin their profit margin is
getting squeezed
right so
you want to keep up with the the
increasing cost of inputs you raise your
price
at what point will we start impacting
the inelasticity demand by the consumer
well obviously
we saw higher sales in 2021 than we did
in 2020 so we haven't gotten there yet
we will but we haven't gotten there yet
on the retail side same thing i have a
number of bullets i'll be happy to send
you my powerpoint you want to read all
these in person but they had labor
difficulty finding labor
difficulty finding plants
some have even come up with the moniker
a plant damage instead of pandemic or
plant damage the shortage of plants
we had the reason i know this is because
i collect data on shrink at the grower
level
and growers had record lows in terms of
the shrink
that they the scrap or the stuff they
threw away or they don't they had record
lows in terms of their strength last
year
why is that because retailers were
calling last year and up until june this
year
send me more product well i don't have
any more product i've sold it i got
something that's smaller it's out of
spec
send it on right i need plants
so growers didn't have to throw away as
many plants as what they typically do so
shrink has been way down
now obviously we have about 18.3
million
new customers
two different sources kind of validated
this there's an axiom marketing study
last year and this year that was
released
in the national gardening survey
both of them showed 18 million
new consumers
the magic question is how many of those
are going to stay
customers
in the long garden sector
i can't answer that question
right if history is prologue
the the consumption goes back to trend
after the recession is over
right so this this is a
man-made recession this is a pandemic
cause recession but it's still recession
two months albeit but we're still seeing
the supply chain dimensions the
inflationary pressures that are
reminiscent
of recessionary times
so let's look postcode with let's turn
our attention all the way i said that
the shape of the of the economic
recovery curve is inversely correlated
with the covid curve and
you can you can match this out right
we've seen
this fourth wave come upon us of the
delta variant and now finally the four
week moving average is going down
hopefully it'll continue going down but
we'll see
last april
for a talk i drew this graph in
powerpoint
and i was showing
that
i'm expecting in the second quarter of
2020 that we're going to see a big
decline which we have and i said we'll
bounce back in the third quarter but
we're not going to get back to normal
right saying we did
and and there you see i said the slope
of the recovery from here depends on how
well we get the health prices under
control
it depends on the pent-up demand
how many businesses go out of business
and then the policy dimensions that were
put in place like the cares act
ppp the payroll protection program
which ended up being very significant
for the horticulture industry and
provided some cash flow that we needed
desperately and in fact many growers and
retailers and landscapers
came into 2021
in the best working capital position
i've ever seen in my entire life
both growing up in the industry and in
academia
i've never seen
the working capital we've seen in this
industry
was my projection correct
yep so far right we saw the decline we
saw the bounce we've seen this general
price increase so the question is how
does that going to look in the future
and the best gauge that i have is what's
called the leading economic index
the leading economic index which is a
foretelling of how the economy is going
to look 11 12 months down the road
and you can see in the last 12 months
during the pandemic this insert right
here at the bottom
this is pretty much
if if history is prolonged again we can
expect this kind of growth over the
course of the next 11 months
now the federal reserve typically agrees
with that in their september
meeting of the federal open market
committee
they said they expect this inflation
which they have been referring to as
transitory
to go down look it's going to be 4.2 for
this year
but they expect to go down to 2.2
percent in 2022 and stay roughly at that
level
that's why you have not seen an interest
rate increase come from the federal
reserve
i think that's
fairly optimistic for the federal
reserve
i think it will go down myself but i
don't know if it'll go down to 2.2
that's for the year mind you
now core inflation is
that same estimate that same headline
estimate you back out energy and food
because those are the things within a
household budget that fluctuate the most
so if you don't eat or drive you're
doing pretty good
but backing that out it's about 3.7 and
then 2.3 and 2.2
and those are those are just rounding
estimates right there why the difference
but here's why this slide is important
have a good class don
he told me he's getting ready to go
teach class so
the federal funds rate
0.1.3
and 1.0
that means that
in september they said that we
anticipate that we will increase
interest rates by about 25 basis points
next year but probably not until the
second half of the year
in 2023 which is the original year they
said they'd raise interest rates we'll
have about 325 basis point increases
that's what they're expecting right now
the way the economy is performing
that's still really cheap money 25 basis
points is basically 0.25
of a percentage point
in the world we're roughly we're just
barely above zero now
so there's still very cheap money
available
now the anticipated growth of the
economy gdp from here on out
is
right here
uh this is slower growth see six point
three percent this year
three and a half percent next year which
is still phenomenal growth
so that's why i'm very bullish
on the lawn and garden sector even going
into next year
but then we're going to come back to
trend even a little bit below trends
because you can't grow at this level
here
and then expect just to go back to trent
you're going to have
some lower than trend growth growth
rates remember this is growth
year-over-year growth
so it's going to slow down a little bit
now housing
why is housing done so well
well millennials
are for the oldest millennials 41 years
of age
so they're they're buying houses
right if they can find a house to buy
because the inventory levels have gone
down to two months
worth of supply now it's back up to six
months without where it should be
plus folks said if i'm gonna have to
stay home during the pandemic
i'm either gonna spruce this place up
which you saw home improvement sales
really increase
or i might as well be at the beach
so i'm going to be zooming in to the
office i might doesn't matter where i
live
so a lot of that demand
and of course
mortgage rates are
redonkulous that's the technical
economic term they're ridiculous
this is so low
new home sales and existing home sales
there is a difference i won't go into
defining that
but they've been stellar
this is the months worth of supply which
was down like i said less than two
months
now it's back up here to six months
we're gradually building inventory you
can see that the number of housing
starts projected
is
really increasing
not to where we were prior to the great
recession but it's around one and a half
million starts per year which is where
we would expect to be with the um
with the demographics we have in the
country
now on the left-hand side look at home
prices
the blue line is the entire country
and the green line is the top 20 cities
the red line is the top 10 cities
the blue line there
this is where housing prices are now
with the case-shiller index right this
is where they are
look at where they were prior to the
great recession
look how much higher they are now
than they were back in the great
recession right here
what caused the great recession
a housing bubble burst in the midst of a
financial crisis
and we see housing prices here
versus where they were when it burst and
caused a great recession
i got my eye on this one
i'm not raising the flag caution flag
just yet because the financial sector
because of dodd-frank is in much better
cash position today than it was
prior to 2007 when lehman brothers
basically brought the house of cards
down
there's none of that occurring in the
financial sector now so it's much more
robust and much more solvent
than it was back then that is a big
difference between now and then that's
why i don't worry about the appreciation
will we see a housing
uh market correction
absolutely
any economist worth his or her salt
we'll tell you there's a correction
coming
when well that's a good question
what does the post covered green
industry look like
again i anticipate that pent up demand
to continue on right but it's going to
be highly dependent on delta
i expect there's going to be more
business closures
and more acquisition activity
i know that because
the number of calls i get from venture
capitalists that are wanting to spread
that black powder around the industry
i get a lot of those calls
when when venture capitalists are are
looking to invest because they hear
charlie hall from american horde or
whatever they want to have 30 minutes by
time just to talk about the industry
i tell them sorry
i don't ever talk to a venture
capitalist you can do your own homework
i'm not because we've not had that much
good black powder come in the industry
and it helped us
it's always hurt us for the most part
so
more constrained supply chains again i
said it's going to be this time next
year before supply chains start
improving
we're going to see a de-risking in the
supply chain
folks you're going to try to move
production
from internationally back global
domestically
region or locally if they can they're
going to try to de-risk the supply chain
all the way from computer chips to
containers everything
it's going to come at a cost
and it's going to take a while to get
there you just can't build a container
manufacturing plant overnight
okay so it takes a while so we're gonna
we're gonna see some of that um the
supply chain disruption continue
once we get the kinks figured out
we will see the bullwhip effect and
that's an economic term where
manufacturers and growers alike and so
forth
it's like cracking a whip when you crack
a whip if you're indiana jones you see
the the big increase and then as the
whip goes out further
they just ride through the supply chain
it's kind of
people sometimes refer to as the pig and
the python right you got this big flood
of inventory moving through
same kind of effect though we will see
that inventory build
and then it'll move through the supply
chain until it normalizes
so we're going to see a surplus
of the plant the plant dimmick right now
will be turned into a plant surplus how
do i know this
i'm 59 years of age and i've seen it
every single time that we've seen in in
the industry where we've had a strong
demand
and uh and a shortage of supply and
we're able to finally able to raise
prices
i've seen the industry respond by
planting the back 40 and the increasing
inventories and i know it's going to
happen again
the only thing stopping it right now is
the growers can't get the inputs to put
the in the inventory
they can't even build greenhouses
because they can't get the greenhouse
manufacturers can't get the steel and
aluminum why because they're steel and
aluminum terrace
right so there's there's a lot of moving
parts here
that just can't be solved by just
increasing consumer demand
there's just a lot of things that have
got to happen sequentially and it's
going to take a while to sort that out
it doesn't happen overnight
freight rates i'm sorry but they're
going to remain high
tonnage is expected to increase and you
have the supply chain disruptions and
the driver shortages that i talked about
there will be more vertical coordination
what i mean by that
in economics you have a vertical
coordination continuum from open market
exchange to dealing on contracts to
dealing in a strategic alliance to
working in a joint venture together both
entities put together equity funds into
a joint venture to total vertical
integration i'm not talking about
integration i'm talking about more
closely aligned
relationships between players in the
industry
either through a strategic alliance or
use of contracts i think we'll see more
of that
there's going to be short-term
constriction in the customer pilot well
why because garden centers are focusing
on the plants they know best
i don't know this to be true bill neal
but i'm i'm suspecting that there'll
maybe be there may be fewer new plant
introductions in the short run
because of it you know we didn't have
a lot of the the breeding and so forth
it was constricted because of the
pandemic we may actually see fewer new
plants i got a question mark there but
i'm supposing that may be the case
e-commerce is going to continue to ramp
up
i know growers within my eagle executive
education program
building up e-commerce applications and
their capabilities to provide eco or
plants by e-commerce
using
artificial intelligence big data
analytics
etc
there's going to be more innovation on
the sustainable side
if i can't get the plastic containers
i'll try these alternative containers
right and we're seeing that in terms of
the demand
logistics innovations warehouse
automation so forth
rising input costs as i mentioned
earlier it's going to continue
but shrink labor and working capital are
still the trifecta in terms of being
profitable
almost finished here there's higher
operating costs of being safe providing
a safe environment for
our worker and customers
surpluses i said are inedible
and then numerous marketing efforts are
underway that's a good thing because we
need to be shouting the benefits of
flowers shrubs and trees at the top of
our voice and then at the same time
though there's the one question
just like
um in the movie city slickers when billy
crystal asked the curler curly what the
secret of life was he said one thing
well there's there's
and jack valance who played curly he
died before he told him the one thing so
i'm getting ready to tell you one thing
and i got to say it hurry so i don't die
before i tell you
but the one thing that i can't answer
what the consumer is going to do i don't
know
what the shape of this curve looks like
right now i suspect it will go back
towards trend
i don't know if we'll remain at this
high elevated demand so with that i'll
close out my presentation i got exactly
three minutes i think for any questions
so thank you very much
oh we've done it one time i have no time
left for questions
you can stick around that's fine
all right thank you very much
thanks to all folks online i know
there's a bunch of folks that weren't
able to make it in person thank you for
being here email me
c dash hall
c dash hall at tamu.edu
and you can have your own copy of the
powerpoint you got a question you can
follow up and i'll be happy to answer it
a quick one what's black powder
oh black powder is the the equity
capital that's brought by um venture
capitalists they refer to that as black
powder is it explosive well it's money
right so it is explosive meaning that if
they inject
if all of a sudden you have a million
dollars of equity coming to your
business
then you can grow your business faster
than you would if you didn't have that
million dollars
so that's that black powder ignites and
it's explosive growth so that's one of
the ways in which you can grow
is to invest
using equity dollars from a venture
capitalist
and and grow your business faster than
you could otherwise but when times go
down
that's when
those folks who may be over leveraged
and know that venture capital is 35
return that's where they may run out of
working capital and then have to go out
of business it's like carolina nurseries
a lot of equity capital in the bank at
the same time
they were they were wanting
their debt capital and form of interest
couldn't pay it so carolina nurseries
went out
anyway yes
you have regular data so you could look
at say
plant sales at garden centers in states
and relate that to policies around covid
so i think it'd be really interesting to
see how
because you have
50 different experiments right and then
your plant sales are pretty local
so it'd be interesting to see what
how policy might have affected this yeah
that's that's a great question and i do
have retail data as part of my national
benchmarking program
and but it's it's uh
it's it's privatized it's you have to
pay a subscription for access to that
data but the short answer is that
depending on the region of the country
they're not all created equal certain
regions had greater growth and greater
uh demand than other regions did
and
obviously garden centers in that region
those regions did better in fact it
ranged from eight percent this year up
to 36
in terms of uh their gross margin
dollars but would that be related to say
vaccinated people or something like that
oh
in fact
you could you could even tie it to red
counties and blue county yes something
like that right yeah
there's a correlation there is there is
that causation i'll leave that for the
individual to make that confirmation but
blue counties outperform red counties
because of the difference in vaccination
levels yeah it's kind of interesting how
that data parses out like that
yes sir do you have any sense of how
this
how these trends relate to carbon
footprint and sustainability
yes i do um
i and dwayne ingram at university of
kentucky we did several life cycle
analyses
of nursery and greenhouse products
and so we know what that carbon
footprint is
now
the influence of covet on that carbon
footprint is that what you're asking
about
i'm just wondering what the shape of
say that the sustainability curve might
be in relation to
this line that you have here
we're talking about carrying capacity
for the basic input resources
yeah that's a great question
i gotta i don't have a an answer that i
would defend right off top of my head
but i would like an opportunity to think
through that one before i gave you an
answer
in other words i don't know
that's that's a good question though
now
i think the the i was on a panel for the
international horticulture producers
about
two weeks ago
now
the dutch and the and the in the uk
they have they're much further along and
asked answering that question than we
are we simply it's a question of data
that we don't have the data in which to
make that correlation but what they have
seen is that there's a strong
correlation right now with the movement
of the higher demand and higher demand
for sustainably produced
lawn and garden products too
plants
i don't know if i answer your question
directly but
that's the best i can do right now yeah
thanks
all right any last questions ultra
pagunto's purple boar
do you want to clean it up
uh okay let's thank
you all right thank you
this has been a production of cornell
university on the web at cornell.edu